la distribución del tiempo de espera
promedio en las filas de comida para
llevar de los restaurantes de una ciudad
es aproximadamente normal con una media
de 185 segundos y una desviación
estándar de 11 segundos adriana sólo se
forman filas de restaurantes cuando el
tiempo de espera promedio se encuentra
en el 10% inferior para esa ciudad
cuál es el máximo tiempo de espera
promedio de los restaurantes en los que
adriana se forma en la fila redondea la
respuesta al segundo más cercano como
siempre si sienten que pueden resolver
esto los invito a que pausa en el vídeo
y traten de resolverlo por su cuenta
resolvamos esto juntos pensemos en qué
es lo que sucede nos dicen que la
distribución del tiempo de espera
promedio es aproximadamente normal
veamos como luce una distribución normal
también nos dan más información de esta
distribución nos dicen que la media es
de 185 segundos y la desviación estándar
es de 11 segundos por ejemplo aquí
tendremos 11 segundos más que la media
por lo que es 196 segundos
aquí tendremos 11 segundos más cada una
de estas líneas punteadas representa una
desviación estándar adicional por arriba
de la media así que aquí tenemos 207
segundos de este otro lado tenemos 11
segundos menos que la media 174 y así
continuamos queremos encontrar el máximo
tiempo de espera promedio de los
restaurantes en los que adriana se forma
en la fila cuáles son estos restaurantes
son aquellos que se encuentran en el 10%
inferior para esa ciudad una forma de
pensar en esto es que debe haber un
valor que vamos a marcar con este color
que será nuestro valor límite de manera
que cualquier cosa que sea igual o menor
a ese valor se encontrará en el 10%
menor de la distribución otra forma de
pensar en esto es que este es el máximo
tiempo de espera promedio que se
encuentra en el 10% menor esta área base
del 10% del total
0.10 la forma en la que vamos a resolver
esto es sacar la tabla zeta y queremos
encontrar cuál es el puntaje z
la proporción de 0.10 que sea menor a
este puntaje z y luego usaremos dicho
puntaje para encontrar el valor del
máximo tiempo de espera
veamos nuestra tabla zeta y ya que
sabemos que esto está por debajo de la
media sabemos que será un puntaje se tan
negativo así que veremos la tabla zeta
que tiene los puntajes negativos
recuerden que nos interesa el 10% pero
no queremos valores mayores a este 10%
queremos asegurarnos de que este valor
se encuentre dentro del percentil 10 lo
que vemos en esta parte de la tabla z no
se acerca para nada a este 10% vamos a
seguir buscando pero recordemos que esta
columna es de las centésimas
aquí hay ceros en las centésimas aquí
tenemos uno aquí dos aquí tres aquí
cuatro y así sucesivamente hasta nueve
recordemos estas columnas si tenemos un
puntaje z de menos 1 punto 28 recuerden
que las columnas de las centésimas van
de 0 1
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete y ocho
así que este puntaje es menos 1.28 que
está un poquito por encima del percentil
10 pero si vemos un puntaje un poco más
negativo que éste nos encontraremos en
el percentil 10 esto es menos 1.29 y
parece ser el máximo puntaje z que se
encuentra dentro del percentil que nos
interesa nuestro puntaje z es menos 1.29
lo escribimos en nuestra gráfica y si
queremos encontrar el valor para este
puntaje comenzaremos con la media que es
185 y decimos que queremos ir 1.29
desviaciones estándar por debajo de la
media el negativo nos dice que estaremos
por debajo de la media menos 1.29 por la
desviación estándar recordamos que la
desviación estándar es de 11 segundos
esto va a ser igual a 1.29 por 11 es
14.19 hacemos que esto sea negativo y a
esto le sumamos 185 lo que nos da 107
punto 81 lo escribimos y nos dicen que
debemos redondear la respuesta al
segundo más cercano hay varias formas de
ver esto si queremos asegurarnos de que
no rebajaremos el percentil 10 entonces
deberemos redondear al segundo más
cercano por debajo de este límite por lo
que podemos decir que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 170 segundos si
redondeamos esto como lo haríamos
normalmente quedaría como 171 segundos
pero al hacerlo así podríamos superar el
límite pero con respecto a este problema
en particular en donde alguien se
preocupa por el tiempo de espera en una
fila la diferencia de un segundo entre
170 y 171 no es nada crucial así que
podemos decir con seguridad que 170 y
171 segundos cumplen con las necesidades
de adriana y con esto terminamos